this video will help you understand
pneumonia and how to manage your
recovery please watch the entire video
to learn how to manage pneumonia
if you have recently been in the
hospital with pneumonia it's important
to understand how to recover properly
when you return home pneumonia is an
infection in one or both of your lungs
the air sacks at the end of your Airways
become inflamed
and fill with fluid causing you to have
difficulty breathing other symptoms of
pneumonia include a cough that may
produce thick mucus
shortness of breath
chest pain when you breathe deeply or
Koff
fever sweating or chills
low body temperature in older adults
muscle aches and fatigue
nausea vomiting or diarrhea
and headache
it's important to understand
that you will still have symptoms as you
recover at home
your coughing should slowly improve
within one to two weeks your appetite
sleeping habits and energy level may
take several weeks before they return to
normal
you will need time off from work and
your normal activity schedule to recover
properly
fortunately you can help manage your
pneumonia by following your health care
teams instructions including taking your
medications as directed
performing self-care procedures
making some lifestyle changes
and protecting your lungs from other
infections and irritants
taking care of yourself means taking our
medications exactly as directed by your
doctor
don't skip doses
don't stop taking your medicine even if
you feel better
take note of any side-effects and tell
your doctor
don't take any over-the-counter
medication or supplement without asking
your doctor first
keep all follow-up appointments with
members of your healthcare team
you can help with your recovery from
pneumonia by doing some simple
procedures at home such as exercising
your lungs throughout your day take a
couple of deep breaths two or three
times an hour deep breaths help to open
up your lungs
coughing up mucus is normal and helps
you clear fluid from your Airways
so only take cough medicine if your
doctor says it's okay
protect those around you and have a
tissue ready to cover your mouth when
you cough and if you cough up mucus
don't swallow it
spit into a tissue and dispose of it
properly
your healthcare team may recommend
postural drainage you can do this by
lying with your head lower than your
chest this position helps drain fluid
from your lungs
maybe prescribed to help you cough up
mucus
to do this lie with your head lower than
your chest and tap your chest firmly
with your hand cupped your healthcare
team can provide you with specific
instructions
a humidifier or vaporizer may help you
to breathe more easily moisture from a
warm bath can also help
changes to your diet can help with your
recovery good nutrition helps your body
fight infection and recover more quickly
a balanced diet includes fruit
vegetables carbohydrates and protein
every day
drink six to eight cups of water juice
or weak tea a day unless your doctor has
told you otherwise
drink alcohol while you are recovering
getting enough sleep also helps your
body to recover more quickly if coughing
interrupts your rest at night take naps
during the day
protect your lungs from irritants don't
smoke or let others smoke around you
stay indoors if air pollution is high
avoid fireplace smoke
protect your lungs from additional
infections by washing your hands often
with soap and hot water
avoid crowds and people with colds or
the flu
ask your doctor if you should have a flu
or pneumonia vaccination
call your doctor if you have more
difficulty breathing
are unable to take a deep breath
have chest pain when you breathe
have a fever that returns
Koff up yellow-green bloody or smelly
mucus
experience vomiting
are excessively sleepy or confused
have impaired thinking
or have blue lips or fingertips